[Música]
i
e
antes de empezar hoy enmendar un
tremendo error cometido imperdonable
imperdonable me olvide mi dúplex mi
compañero de travesía
brad por favor
esto entra verdad
él no habla
40.000 personas
40.000 personas una cada 15 minutos son
las muertes súbitas en nuestro país tan
sólo en un año
[Música]
el 70% de ellas ocurren fuera del ámbito
hospitalario lejos de las guardias es
decir en la vida pública con un
desconocido
en la escuela con un alumno en casa con
un familiar
o por qué no
en una presentación de terex no no no
hoy no
no quiero trabajar
por mi nombre es cesar daniel palacios
soy introductor en 1º saco rojos urbanos
e introductor en primeros auxilios y
gestión de riesgos en la dirección de
general de defensa civil y emergencia
urbana
mi tarea cotidiana es conjuntamente con
mis compañeros y comprar es recorrer
instituciones día a día
impartiendo ese tipo de instrucciones
para preparar a la comunidad para la
distinta amenaza la que está dispuesto
no es la única de marquense médica hoy
vamos a abordar una marca
y puntualmente del paro
cardiorrespiratorio
yo voy a presentar a unos amigos cuatro
amigos
eso es gladys barrios
la lee para los amigos es maestra
jardinera
es micaela martínez en ese momento 19
años tan sólo 19 años
me faltan 22 amigos más en la imagen de
los míos no también se trata de verónica
pedraza portera de un jardín de infantes
joven sea pero un profe de tecnología de
la misma institución en la zona norte la
ciudad
que los une a esos cuales vio conductor
que reconocieron la emergencia médica en
sus alumnos y que ejecutaron reanimación
cardiopulmonar las siglas rcp
que permite estos esos cuatro niños que
fueron que recibieron los primeros
auxilios sobrevivieron el incidente es
decir que tienen un futuro que siguen
respirando y que van a crecer
pero lamentablemente este la excepción a
nuestra pena ser realidad a estos nuevos
habitual en nuestra ciudad de córdoba
ustedes creen que tocan los docentes los
centros de signar en la vía pública lo
estamos tocando aquí habíamos tirado
delante nuestro
este es el paradigma que tenemos que cap
a tocar el paciente
hay muchos casos más muchos otros
docentes muchísimos más
traje cuatro amigos nada más
le voy a pedir por favor ahora que
colaboran conmigo y me han sentí parte
de ustedes que levante la mano cuántos
de ustedes sabían que la línea de
emergencia médica en la ciudad de
córdoba en 107 por favor
y estamos casi en un 50% es decir que
hay mucha gente vulnerable en la sala no
sabéis quién sabrá una emergencia médica
el riesgo inminente de vida en los
próximos minutos se muere el sitio tengo
que saber a quién llamar a quién activar
quién va a venir en mi auxilio
y ahora levanten la mano
por favor cuántos de ustedes han hecho
el curso de rcp en los últimos cinco
años
son unos cuantos me sorprende esto es
otra favorablemente
no va a llegar a la ambulancia no va a
llegar a tiempo en una ciudad otras
cifras cifras
a ver nuestra ciudad de córdoba ahí la
tenemos nuestra ciudad de correo de uno
de los ejidos municipales más extendidos
de américa lo sabían esto
576 kilómetros cuadrados de extensión
una ciudad muy grande muy extendida
el segundo dato
que por cada minuto que pasa una víctima
que está curso en un paro
cardiorrespiratorio pierde un 10% de
posible de sobrevida si no lo tocamos
pierden un 10% de posibilidad sobre vida
me siguen
y por último 7 datos yo quiero que
ustedes se enojen conmigo nos tenemos
que enojar alguna vez o no si es válido
y nos tenemos que enojar casi el 80% la
llama que ingresa en el link emergencia
107 son de bromistas o falsas
activaciones
un espanto no coinciden conmigo los
tenemos que revertir esto porque hay una
ciudad tan grande con un tránsito tan
fluido tan complicado
con tanta casuística que tenemos una
cada 15 minutos y si luego usó el
teléfono para bromas o falsas
activaciones la ambulancia no va a
llegar a tiempo sobre todo con un
familiar cuando en un lazo afectivo que
me une la persona que está delante vaya
qué te parece
tenemos que sacarnos este mito encima de
una vez por todas y no tocar
yo vengo a esto mi misión es que no se
enojen y empecemos a tocar a tocarlo y
muchos pacientes ese mito lo tenemos que
despejar definitivamente y no quede ni
rastro de él
muchas instituciones de otra ciudad
viene de otro curso de primeros auxilios
hay muchas no es únicamente defensa
civil yo tengo mi corazón ahí en defensa
civil os damos este curso gratuito a lo
largo de todo el año dos veces al mes
por lo menos en distintos horarios
yo lo estoy invitando tengo mi corazón
ay discúlpenme pero hay muchas
instituciones la ciudad que lo que
brinda este taller gratuito también
y ahora si lo voy a utilizar abra mi
compañero
voy a utilizar para que vean ustedes
y vamos a hacer la presencia una persona
tirada en la vía pública
lo que no estamos haciendo está hoy lo
primero antes de todo carlos verificar
mi seguridad
nada me lastimé a mí así la ayuda es
efectiva entonces la mirada integral de
la escena y resina y lo voy a abordar
una vez que estoy seguro me voy a
arrodillar delante de él y voy a hacer
un estímulo doloroso debe ejercer dolor
un estímulo doloroso entre el hombro y
el cuello en el trapecio que voy a
generar dolor para que harsich y quite
los hombros abre los ojos algún tipo de
reacción volcán si no lo conozco no sé
qué es brad hoy en vía pública
le voy a gritar a ambos oídos señor me
escucha señor un estímulo auditivo al se
quitó la cabeza no responde de ninguna
manera no respondió a ningún estímulo en
ese momento subí a activar el servicio
médico de emergencias esto lo que
determina el código rojo famoso en los
servicios médicos de emergencias el
estado de conciencia del paciente para
ello vive valor de alguien estoy en vía
pública mente muy barrer de alguien voy
a responsabilizar a una persona tu
nombre
milagros por favor 10 7 adulto
inconsciente si milagros bien les
responsabilizó a necesito contacto con
ella que me conteste no tiene baje la
vista este dubitativa nervioso se vacía
pues se va a ir esté en otro
comportamiento hoy en la comunidad otro
que tiene que cambiarlo milagro está
llamando voy a seguir saqueando mi
segundo chequeo es verificar si respiro
no si esa caja toráxica en movimiento
ventilatorio si se mueve la caja si en
traer o no verificó si no se mueve la
caja no está respirando no sin signos
vitales
milagros no respirar voy a empezar el
reset
esto no lo escuché nunca en mis años del
teléfono 207
donde vamos a comprimir boca el estómago
lo buscamos el apéndice soy de esa s
carta y luego tiene filo y finaliza en
una punta punta de lanza que se llora
que no la quiere fracturar reborde
costal sin muy guarda la persona como yo
digamos la boca del estómago dos dedos
protegemos a punta s carta y luego talón
de la mano en medio punto de apoyo en el
eje centro del esternón ahí
lo buscamos talón de la mano
entre la samba los dedos para que sea
y el talón el que apoye me levanta la
mano voy a trabar los codos lo voy a
dejar apendicular el tórax a 90 grados y
voy a dejar caer el peso mi cuerpo
solamente dejando caer el peso de mi
cuerpo en el tórax permitido después la
expansión completa de la caja
a esta velocidad
casi dos compresiones por segundo
cuánto tiempo de gastar a qué comprar
hasta que llegue la ambulancia va a
demorar la ambulancia
si el tiempo que voy a estar acá puede
ser importante
lo que a mí le dice que no pero si mi
hija lo camino
voy a comprimir
entre 3 y 5 minutos lo voy a dejar voy a
controlar nuevamente la caja a ver si
ventiló no y otros cinco minutos más así
hasta que llegue la ambulancia lo que
demore y esto lo enfatizó lo que demore
la ambulancia yo no vi detener la
maniobra en velocidad frecuencia
intensidad
de mis manos
depende la posibilidad sobre vida del
las posibles orillas decaen muy
rápidamente ustedes bien saben que entre
cuatro y seis minutos que ese cerebro no
recibe nutrientes
y muerte cerebral cerebral en sí solo y
proporciones en nutrientes bombeando en
forma mecánica esto el rcp una pavada
literalmente vital lo que hacemos
tengo un escritor de cabecera que me
encanta nos acercamos en su novela la
peste él nos escribe que la mejor manera
de conocer una ciudad
es averiguar cómo se trabaja en esa
cómo se llama y cómo se muere
como si un atrevido por naturaleza lo
vio transformar a camus en cordobés
quién lo va a escribir en córdoba
y la mejor manera de conocer la ciudad
de córdoba es averiguar
como presenciar cómo reaccionamos ante
un paro cardiorrespiratorio en la vida
pública y ver qué hacen nuestros vecinos
como ejecutan rct y como reconocen no
señoras
señores
tocar o no tocar es la cuestión en
cambiar este paradigma no va
literalmente la vida
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
y
sí
[Música]
i